[Musique]
[ __ ] super je sors de chez le dermato
il m'a coupé l'oreille l'avait acquise
de gros comme un pépin de raisin
quelle horreur c'est un peu tard bas le
grand mot car on retient est mon petit
théo le grand moteur octarine on donne
de la force à petit merci c'est sympa le
nom s'affiche ici en bas de votre écran
[ __ ] j'ai peur on doit me faire monter
en ce moment j'ai pris michaela docteur
oui oui mais tu ta pote
non tu es suis pas tu tapote sur le toit
un placement faire je suis médecin
arrêté médecins là bas dans ton bled à
ses propres fonds
il a fait du bon travail
mon quota concept on arrive à la plaine
il découvre son petit bulletin
[Musique]
je suis très énervé très énervé parce
que j'ai été chez le barbier pour la
première fois de ma vie tout à l'heure
par le moustachu en l'occurrence et à la
fin au moment de régler le mec me dit
non ne paye pas t'inquiète c'était
rapide ça m'a pris cinq minutes banon
bah non pourquoi tous les mecs qui
viennent de passer juste avant moi ils
ont payé
qu'est ce qu'elle a ma moustache et les
différentes des autres non je veux payer
trop d'argent
merde je reçois plein de messages
concernant l'avant première des gains
alors bien sûr que je serai présente
j'ai hâte de tous vous voir et vous
regarde le film tous ensemble ça va être
trop table ça se voit sa belle épine
dans le 94
je fais des gros bisous les amis retour
à paris par la route des crêtes
ces gens paniquent après quelques
petites vidéos pour ceux qui sont un peu
contemplative comme moi tous en merco
décapotable bref c'est le petit plus
non
non poulou
salut c'est kevin c'est qu'il y trouver
quoi la couleur des cheveux lajarrige et
voilà je vous embrasse mais c'est un
grand honneur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]